it is quite literally the foundational
material of modern civilization
concrete in foundations for power
stations like this
in bridges roads buildings and railways
like hs2
it is the very skeleton of britain's
physical economy
so much so that we sometimes take it for
granted but concrete and its crucial
ingredients cement
are now at the heart of a very big issue
indeed
now when you think about net zero what
probably comes to mind cars
planes power stations but arguably
what's happening in
cement plants like this in this country
and around the world is just as if not
more important
for the future of the planet what we do
here is we take chalk and clay
and we introduce it to this rotary kiln
that you can see behind you
where it's heated to 1500 degrees
centigrade
and converted into cement
we are changing the formulation of
concrete
to a much lower carbon uh recipe
using lots of alternative materials
that matters because cement production
accounts for about seven percent of
global co2 emissions
that's even bigger than all aviation and
deforestation combined
and here's the key thing cement
emissions come from two sources
first the energy used to heat the kilns
but even more so the chemical reaction
going on inside that rotating tube
this plant uses renewable fuels
essentially processed rubbish for the
energy bit
but that still leaves the chemical
reaction one option is to try to capture
those emissions and put them back
underground
but that won't happen without
intervention cement is it's a commodity
industry the margins aren't big
so you can't expect companies to do this
out of the goodness of their hearts
so it's got to be regulated and it's got
to be fair
so you know ideally all we should set a
timetable for decarbonizing cement
across the whole of europe
or how about getting rid of concrete
altogether not an option
the idea that we could wean ourselves
off concrete
in any kind of time frame i think isn't
realistic
actually given the amount of development
that's going on
the the amount of um building that's
happening globally
so we we have to tackle the root
cause which is to to look at um
decarbonizing the cement every system
will be rough
uh can be mixed roughly the same amount
of time but might the answer lie here
in these test tubes at the university of
sheffield that's
the zero co2 system that's right that
cement in the test tube on the right was
made without any of the direct carbon
emissions caused by traditional cement
manufacturer
it's just as strong in most applications
and maybe even more resilient
leaving one question can we just replace
traditional cement
with this stuff the short answer is no
and that's because
one of the biggest challenges that we
have with these materials with any
replacement for portland cement
is to be able to produce it on a scale
that can meet the demand for cement and
concrete
and so to be able to produce an
alternative material at the same scale
is very very challenging all of which is
why concrete
boring lifeless concrete is fast
becoming the most exciting
dynamic field in climate science unless
we solve these problems
net zero will remain a pipe dream
ed conway sky news